He lives in her heart. He lives in Staten Island. I live in Staten Island.
He lives in a Midtown big Trump building. Yeah. He doesn't live there. No.
Well, I think, I think they say he lives there and he lived somewhere else. I,
I, I could, I would, yeah, I would, uh, your phone for him.
I get your phone for the first time.
He's filled out a clause in the first time you're full out of the closet.
Conservative. Know what? Let me be honest with you. Honest with you. I was,
if you were to talk to me a week ago, I would say, yeah, guaranteed Trump 2020,
but I don't know. I went to this concert, the 1975 concert and I was around,
I was around a lot of liberals and they a very liberal band. And I was like,
I liked these guys' music. I liked this guy's message.
I was listened to what he said about climate change and then singing his songs
with great avant thunking, Berg, whatever his name is. Greg was like,
and I was like, you know, these people aren't as bad as I thought, you know,
it's like, I mean, they're annoying. And I'm like, all right, shut up.
But I feel like I could be sweating now to vote just because of how
nice they were left because they're nice people, but I probably don't.
I vote for no. What I like about your opinions? Do you have a staff?
You have a sound understanding of policy.
That's why I liked the way you low based on emotion.
You go right for policy and, and things that matter. Like the biggest,
the things that matter the most are what to you in politics in politics. Wow.
Guy. You're asking him a question.
That's that's a little over his head in politics. Um, here's what I'll say.
I'm a weird guy. It's like, I want, I believe 100%, uh,
in, um, in pro choice. I believe it's a woman's right to choose. Absolutely. Um,
I think religion should be 100% out of politics.
I don't think he should have any effect on anything. Um,
and I also just want the wall, so I don't know that it's just,
you cannot not the wall, but it's like,
you can't have people just walk in and out of here. Yeah. I understand that.
A mirror, what?
The wall and a catapult for the ones who get locked in here that you can put
them over.
I understand that America is just lines on a map that some guy made up. Yeah.
That guy's Jesus. He's just some guy.
That's a guy disrespectful. Yeah. Jesus. it. What are you?
What are you working for? Islam now? Yeah. Yeah. Wow.
We're going to have to cackle this whole episode that Jesus and his mother,
they made up, it was basically an arts and crafts project with married mother.
Jesus and Jesus made up America. Yeah. Yeah.
Before you were playing around now you get serious. Yeah.
That's why you paid attention in history class. Cause you know? Yeah.
I don't know. So it's not that I want the actual wall, but it's like, you can't,
you just want the Chinese out. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. And that's basically what I,
what about the Japanese and the Koreans you follow up trying to
[inaudible] your fans know that everything on here is all that they do.
But once in a while, a new listeners freak out,
nobody's actually ever said one bad thing. It's a comedy podcast.
It's a character. I'm just kidding around joking.
Because I'm going to stuff is true though. Yeah. Somebody just stuffing
he's really gay. No, that is, that is true though. I don't want the wall,
but I just, I just, you know, um, I'm all for tight immigrant. It's like,
I'm gonna, you know what? I don't want gray area kid. I don't want the wall.
I think that I don't want the walls, but I think it should be amazed.
I think they should have. Yeah. I think it should be a lot harder to do. Yeah.
You gotta be smart enough to get it here.